vous m'avez s'est serré la main j'ai
senti vraiment une bonne poignée de main
ouais ça fait plaisir ouais voici denis
chatelier à la suite d'un accident
cet ancien peintre en bâtiment avait
perdu ses deux mains en 1996 quatre ans
plus tard il bénéficie d'une greffe à
l'hôpital edouard herriot de lyon
une première mondiale dirigée par le
professeur jean michel dubernard
au total l'intervention a duré 17 heures
pour la réussir pas moins de dix-huit
chirurgien épaulé par une cinquantaine
de spécialistes internationaux se sont
relayés dans le bloc opératoire
l'opération réalisée dans le cadre d'un
programme de recherche clinique n'est
pas sans risque quelques jours après la
greffe le professeur avertissez sur les
effets secondaires les risques de cancer
les risques de complications sont connus
précisait il y a deux tubes heures plus
qu'ils sont partis qui sont plus
fréquentes chez les transplantés
premièrement d'études heures plus tard
un deuxième mort il ya des infos en 2003
trois ans après l'opération
la greffe est considérée comme réussie
le traitement anti rejet efficace denis
chatelier commence même à retrouver peu
à peu la sensibilité de ses doigts je
peux toucher pas mal de choses et ne
reprendra pas l'écriture ma musique mes
gosses il en est là nan les cheveux
grâce à ces nouvelles mains le greffé et
c'est aussi d'éveiller les consciences
comme en 2008 sur le plateau du journal
de david pujadas
on a greffé demain on a fait une greffe
du visage
bientôt pourquoi qu'on pourrait prendre
effet un jour à pied ouvre une jambe le
projet le projet il faut que l'on se
lance dans une aventure aussi merci je
tiens à sous et normand de l'eure un
appel un appel au don d'organes
cette opération était novatrice dans le
domaine des transplantations depuis
d'autres patients ont reçu une greffe
des deux mains en france
le dernier en date jean michel schryve
en 2016 16 ans après denis chatelier
[Musique]